[Aplausos]
este silencio
es el que existía en el escenario
político antes de que pacma irrumpiera
en como partido político en nuestro país
hace ya 15 años mi nombre es silvia
barquero soy la presidenta de pacma el
partido animalista que defiende los
derechos de los animales en un país como
españa cuyas fiestas nacionales son las
corridas de toros donde se ahorcan
galgos y se abandonan cientos de miles
de animales cada año
un partido político que crece
constantemente duplicando resultados
cada vez que nos presentamos a unos
nuevos comicios un partido apoyado por
cientos de miles de personas que como yo
y como otras muchísimas somos activistas
que dedicamos nuestro tiempo libre
nuestro dinero toda nuestra energía a
ayudar a los animales en protectoras
donde colaboramos limpiando cheniles
sacando a los animales a pasear
rescatando cuidando dándoles las
necesidades veterinarias de animales que
han sufrido lo indecible muchas veces
personas que dedican su tiempo libre a
alimentar a los gatos abandonados de la
calle en colonias que existen en
nuestras ciudades dándoles de comer
dándoles todos los cuidados 24 horas al
día 7 días a la semana 365 días al año
sin vacaciones sin festivos dedicando
todo nuestro corazón a los más
necesitados de los que nunca nadie habla
personas que nos manifestamos en las
calles para dar voz a los animales en
rechazo a prácticas como la tauromaquia
o la caza
yo me convertí en la presidenta de un
partido político pero me siento de
corazón activista por los animales y esa
es toda mi trayectoria llevo 15 años
trabajando para cambiar la injusta
situación que padecen los animales en
nuestro país y os quería contar una
experiencia personal
cuando tenía unos 11 años recuerdo que
vivía con mis padres
y en el barrio donde vivíamos una tarde
paseando
y escuché el sonido lastimero de un
gatito que lloraba como sólo saben hacer
estos animales para llamar nuestra
atención así que pues bueno yo era una
niña y alarmada busque donde estaba ese
gato y llegué a una cabina de teléfonos
donde había una caja y me encontré a un
gatito malherido debió ser atropellado y
yo cogí la caja sin dudarlo y me lo
llevé a casa y pase una noche terrible
una noche de frustración y de
desesperanza porque no pude paliar el
sufrimiento de ese animal y hace tanto
tiempo de esto que en la zona donde yo
vivía no había clínicas veterinarias de
urgencias donde poder llevar a este gato
así que afortunadamente por la mañana
mis padres me acercaron a una protectora
y allí me ayudaron a cuidar a este
gatito pero pero él se ha convertido
para mí en el momento en el que decidí
dedicar mi vida a paliar el sufrimiento
de los animales me conmovió tanto no
poder hacer nada por él que creo que a
futuro pensé que la única manera de
de paliar lo que no había podido hacer
era dedicando mi vida a ayudar a los
animales
somos un partido político es verdad
formado por personas que piensan como yo
y como seguramente cada vez más personas
en nuestro país porque nos hemos
convertido en una corriente social
imparable que los animales sufren y
sienten como nosotros y que esa es la
cualidad moralmente relevante para
tenerles en consideración para
incluirles en nuestro círculo de
consideración moral yo es una persona
empática profundamente empática también
me he dedicado a ayudar a personas que
necesitaban aprender castellano que
venían de fuera y ha dado clases
gratuitas de castellano y lo que me ha
movido siempre son las injusticias así
que creo que ha llegado el momento de
incluir a los animales en nuestra en
nuestro círculo de consideración moral
porque si sienten y sufren como nosotros
ese sufrimiento ha de ser evitado
y esto no lo decimos ya las personas que
trabajamos por los derechos y los
intereses de los animales sino que a
nivel científico ha sido reconocido en
la declaración de cambridge que fue un
encuentro que se realizó en 2012 en esta
universidad donde eminentes biólogos
veterinarios y neurocientíficos llegaron
a la conclusión de que los animales
tienen las estructuras biológicas que al
igual que los seres humanos nos hacen
percibir el entorno que nos procuramos
lo que nos beneficia y evitamos lo que
nos perjudica y esto es lo que nos hace
iguales a los animales y ellos han
demostrado y han declarado a nivel
científico que los animales sienten pero
no sólo eso si seguimos la línea de las
nuevas investigaciones incluso se ha
demostrado que seres tan distintos a
nosotros mamíferos vertebrados incluso
los peces los peces son capaces de ser
conscientes de sí mismos son auto
conscientes porque cuando alguien es
consciente desde luego es porque hay
alguien detrás de unos ojos que nos
miran esos seres son alguien y no algo y
esto es lo que estamos tratando de
trasladar al plano legal
y las leyes para conseguir que protejan
a los animales de manera efectiva
en un país como el nuestro decía donde
se abandonan cientos de miles de
animales donde miles de ellos son
torturados en plazas de toros o por qué
no hablar también de aquellos que están
ocultos tras los muros de granjas
industriales y mataderos en nuestro país
millones y millones de animales son
ejecutados sistemáticamente a un ritmo
frenético en mataderos donde se vulneran
sus intereses más básicos donde los
animales que han padecido una vida de
hacinamiento confinación y miseria donde
nunca han visto los rayos del sol porque
han sido criados en granjas donde las
leyes europeas permiten que se ampute el
rabo a los cerdos sin anestesia antes de
los 7 días de vida porque se considera
que esos animales quizás no sienten el
dolor de unas tijeras que les cortan el
rabo o que les extraen los colmillos sin
anestesia después de una vida de
confinamiento donde no han podido
disfrutar de sus congéneres de una
relación afectiva con sus madres como
sucede con los terneros que son
separados de sus madres
a las que luego se extrae la leche para
nuestro uso son llevados a mataderos
donde son testigos de la muerte del
animal que va delante de ellos donde
escuchan los chillidos de los animales
que están siendo ejecutados delante de
ellos donde perciben incluso el olor de
la sangre de los animales que están
siendo ejecutados esa es la terrible
realidad de los animales que no están
protegidos a nivel legal y eso es lo que
nosotros pretendemos lo que las personas
que tenemos empatía hacia los animales
pretendemos cambiar y es cierto que hay
una corriente social imparable que
afortunadamente está haciendo realidad
una nueva manera de ver el mundo y de
estar en el mundo yo recuerdo que cuando
me hice vegetariana y por supuesto por
motivos éticos pero también por motivos
medioambientales
era casi imposible encontrar leche
vegetal en los supermercados ahora la
decisión es tan sencilla como en la
estantería del supermercado girar la
mano un poco más a la derecha oa la
izquierda y encontrar pues leche de
almendras leche de soja leche de arroz o
de otras muchísimas variedades esto hace
15 años era realmente impensable hace 15
años hubiera sido impensable
literalmente que se hubieran cambiado
las leyes como lo que ha sucedido ahora
en españa donde en 2017 y gracias a la
presión que hacemos como partido
político se aprobó con 30 años es verdad
de retraso con el resto de partidos de
países europeos el convenio europeo de
protección de los animales y es verdad
que ahora afortunadamente podemos decir
que en nuestro país ya no se puede
amputar por motivos estéticos las orejas
o el rabo a los perros oa los gatos se
les pueden cortar incluso las cuerdas
vocales o de singular y esto es
necesario para su propio bienestar es
impensable que podamos que pudiéramos
seguir haciendo esto a los animal
afortunadamente también podemos decir
que en nuestro país en cada comunidad
autónoma donde se va cambiando la ley de
protección animal se están prohibiendo
incluso los circos con animales como ya
ha sucedido en más de 25 países en toda
europa y afortunadamente podemos decir
que en nuestro país se va avanzando en
la legislación aunque lentamente
precisamente por eso me siento
afortunada de haber formado parte de
esta creciente sensibilidad en favor de
nuestros compañeros de planeta
porque si no le ponemos fin a la
explotación de los animales estaremos
contribuyendo también de manera directa
con el cambio climático que es la mayor
amenaza planetaria a la que nos estamos
enfrentando así que con un paso firme y
la mirada al frente sabemos que vamos
lento pero tenemos claro el objetivo
hacia dónde nos dirigimos estamos
alcanzando grandes cambios que hubieran
sido impensables hace 15 años que
quienes hemos experimentado toda esta
trayectoria del movimiento en favor de
los animales nos admiramos de como la
sociedad nos ha ido acompañando en este
en este cambio sabemos que vamos a
lograr
es el cambio necesario para los animales
también a nivel político y legal y como
como dijo otto von bismarck los
políticos trabajan por las nuevas
elecciones por las siguientes elecciones
nosotros trabajamos por las siguientes
generaciones para dejar un mundo mejor
para todos los habitantes de nuestro
planeta para nosotros para los animales
por el medio ambiente
aquí está para cma muchísimas gracias
gracias